[Music]
good morning everyone
and welcome to Google Cloud next I'm
delighted to have all of you here with
us today and to the tens of thousands
joining us virtually from across the
region thank you so much for tuning in
and for those of you here in Munich it's
been three years three whole years since
we've had the chance to connect face to
face at a next event and we have a lot
to catch up on and today we'll be
looking at the transformative power of
cloud technology and how it can help
drive your organization's transformation
forward
in the past few years Renault Alliance
and Seb have both aggressively been
pursuing transformation strategies
and for both organizations Cloud
technology sits at the very core of
their transformations
share more about this bold course of
action please join me in welcoming two
leaders Renault alliance's vice
president of I.T Services Stefan van ook
and Petro uland head of Tech and the
group executive committee member from
Seb please join me and welcome to the
stage
thank you
[Music]
thank you Stefan please take a seat
great to have you so thank you so much
for being with us maybe we start off by
helping the audience here to understand
a little bit about the vision for
transformation that you have in your
company Stefan let's start with you on
the Renault story when we say
transformation we mean transformation
across all area of the business
first a new approach to our product is
completely changing what is delivered to
its customer from offering just vehicle
we are moving to offering Mobility
Services our vision is that 20 of our
Revenue will come from Services by 20 to
30. this means a new approach to product
development to deliver and rectify
connected and software defined vehicle
by 2025.
second we are changing the company
business operating model all operations
will be cloud-based data-driven and EI
enabled we need to gain in agility and
stability improve security and at the
same time continuously provide new
Services the cloud delivered the best
platform for us to drive these
opportunities
sdb was formed 165 years ago so this
will definitely not be our first
transformation we are a wholesale bank
but we're also one of the largest iot
organization in the nordics banking
range is about itun data that's where we
meet our customers expectations with new
Innovative services and we believe
traditional banks with our key asset in
people and funds can use the cloud in
very powerful ways to be the best banks
of tomorrow
digital transformation is critical to
our ability to succeed with these
business goals and from a technology
standpoint we have a set Vision to be
Cloud native by 2030. Google is a
critical part of our digital
transformation we are working on the
end-to-end process from a car design to
its launch through the manufacturing
quality check Supply Chain management
and delivery to the dealers the car
usage will be then monitored analyzed
using our care data platform for a
better understanding of our customers
honey was also connected over 30
manufacturing plant and the associated
supply chain to the Google Cloud
platform in order to collect data we are
switching to data-driven manufacturing
and supply chain models our first
strategy was multi-cloud then we
switched to a gcp first
Beyond trust the Renault group choose
Google has a partner for multiple
reasons Google cloud is offering the
best value for money Google cloud is
offering two Cloud flexibility and
ability to respond to short and
long-term challenges uh and Cloud the
Google cloud data is the best value
proposal on today's market and then of
course the Google teams are very skilled
and very supportive to any of our
challenge Patrick how are you at SCB
working with Google on the other digital
transformation efforts that you have in
the company yeah when we started our
journey to become Cloud native we
evaluated many options and why we're
setting on a multi-cloud strategy Google
cloud has supplied all the functionality
we've needed so far
but more than that their true
partnership in helping us solve
challenging problems through an
integrated approach of collaboration
technology and training has really been
an asset for us
and in a highly regulated industry
building trust is a foundation for
personalized Services it's enabled by
technology for security know your
customer and compliance
so our role is very much to enable
companies and individuals to make
choices that contribute to sustainable
Society our experience of working with
Google is that Google combines both the
stability reliability and responsibility
of a major Enterprise
and also the speed Innovation and
flexibility of a startup
to Echo a dare across Europe Middle East
and Africa now more than ever
cloud is essential for digital
transformation
cloud has to deliver more value and more
Innovation to organizations from
understanding your customers better
helping you make your supply chain more
resilient bringing people together to
improve not just their productivity but
their creativity
and creating seamless interactions
across your entire value chain
we're committed at Google Cloud through
the digital transformation of all
businesses across Europe Middle East and
Africa and the continued investments in
Cloud on Europe's terms to support
sovereignty
security and sustainability
the transformation era of cloud is
marked by a completely different kind of
conversation
how do we become the best at
understanding and using data
how do we ensure we have the best
technology infrastructure
how do we know that our data our systems
and our users are secure
how do we create the best workplace for
our people
and how do we collectively create
a more sustainable future
how does an organization actually become
the best at understanding in using their
data you know it turns out data is at
the heart of digital Innovation and it's
really the key to unlocking AI
Google is a leader in the analysis of
structured and unstructured data and we
are unifying the data ecosystem for you
creating the most open data cloud
and this includes actually all of your
data in all of your formats from all
sources from any clouds and collectively
it's about enabling all styles of
analysis and the first stop is business
intelligence
in the business intelligence space let's
be honest we actually have two sets of
data on the one side there is
centralized highly governed and
well-managed data it's used for
standardized three percent dashboards
and on the other side well we have that
not so much official data it's often
distributed and it's many times used for
self-service dashboarding right Google
has products for both of these worlds
first we have looker it is the leading
product for governed data access it has
strong business semantics and it's
really the foundation for data driven
application building
and we have Google cloud data Studio
it's one of the most popular tools for
self-service data visualizations and
discovery
and today we announced that we are
unifying these two products into a
single offering called looker and lucra
studio and with that actually we're
going to unify self-service bi with
trusted data
we are also announcing looker Studio Pro
Luca Studio Pro is an enhancement of
that with additional support and
management capabilities
we understand
that to fully Embrace transformation in
the cloud
you not only need security
you also need Trust
you need confidence and peace of mind
that when you deploy the latest
Innovations
you can meet your unique requirements
for control
transparency and sovereignty
whether that's driven by your regulator
by geopolitical considerations or indeed
by the government and its policy
at Google Cloud we take a digital
sovereignty seriously
customers Partners policy makers and
governments have surfaced three
requirements in three very specific
areas
the first is data sovereignty which is
keeping control over encryption and
access to your data
the second is operational sovereignty
this is keeping visibility and control
over the provider operations
and the third is software sovereignty
this is running workloads without a
dependence on a provider software
to address these requirements we
launched our initiative Cloud on
Europe's terms in September of 2021 to
support data residency requirements we
continue to launch Cloud regions in emea
just recently we launched new regions in
Qatar the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and
Greece adding to our 16 Cloud regions
here in emea and today I'm really
excited to announce new Cloud regions
for four more countries for Austria for
Norway for Sweden and South Africa our
unique relationship with t-systems in
Germany here demonstrates how we deliver
both the full benefit of the public
cloud and confidence in compliance with
German regulations
and to discuss this I'd really like to
welcome on stage Adele outside a CEO of
two systems please join me in welcome
Nadal
thank you
hello there great to have you here Adele
thank you thank you so much so t-systems
uh was Google's Cloud's first digital
sovereignty partner in Europe and as you
know since then we've partnered in
France in Spain and in Italy and
probably more to come but it started
with you yes
um why do you think this partnership
model is so important not just for
Germany but in Europe and Beyond well
there first of all thank you for having
me it's great to be in a room full of
people again
um you know sovereignty has been a topic
for a period of time this is not a new
topic right
um it's driven by multiple factors
um geopolitical tensions is driving it
the bifurcation of the world between
East and West the fear of being
dependent on somebody and not being able
to move
is another
the war in Europe that we didn't expect
is fueling even more this sovereignty
sentiment
and at the core of it as I said this
fear of dependency but also fear of not
complying with regulatory environments
and you talked about data data is a big
deal here right how do I control my data
how do I make sure I know exactly who is
touching it where is it Etc
and um we've seen this opportunity
develop over multiple years
um and we found this opening where we
worked jointly with you to develop the
engineering solution
um and um you know I'm super excited
about that because it is a unique way of
providing a hyperscalar solution with
the Sovereign controls that allows
company digitize allows them to use the
best of the cloud without losing their
sovereignty and their worries about
control so as our companies perform a
risk assessment you know often looking
at what The Regulators have suggested I
think there's a very strong sense that
the time to act as now as you said this
solution is available and that's because
of the upside that is significant so if
I asked you about that upside what would
excite you most about it look there's a
lot of things that I'm I'm super excited
about I'm excited first of all about
this
engineering solution that addresses
European concern
this is a unique solution
it doesn't compromise in terms of access
to the hyperscaler stacks and all of the
exciting technology that you just
learned so I'm excited about bringing it
to the market and and showcasing it and
bringing customers on it I'm excited
about onboarding our clients
you know we're learning as we as we
bring every client on board and and that
makes us stronger that makes us revisit
our road maps and decide what to
prioritize
so let me thank you once again for
placing your trust in Google Cloud
Google is investing for the future
and we are here to help whatever comes
next
[Music]